welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day three and
we're gonna learn the routines of
billionaires
[Music]
enjoy
[Music]
you talked about in support of the 996
work routine and i've got to underscore
to those who don't know it in particular
in china
you work 9 a.m to 9 00 p.m six days a
week
and you were given a hard time because
of that and you backed off a little bit
no 996
is the spirit that i encouraging alipapa
people
if you want have a bright future if you
don't wanna be give up by the society
it won't be successful you have to work
hard
of course you can enjoy life you know i
work only two hours a day and
can you can you enjoy life with a 996
regime yes i do
i do do other people in shenzhen and
elsewhere i
i i think most of the people in this
world
whether the great president whether a
good professor
or a good engineer a good scientist a
good anchor
like you you work much more than you do
when i have a shower i think i work when
i'm the toilet
i think when i running i think
we never stop working because today
why alibaba need to 996 because we on
our side
we have more than 60 million business
rely on us
if we don't work hard they lose their
hope
so we have to work hard but but
if you don't like your job if you don't
like the work you do
working two hours a day you feel very
bad
if you love your jobs people like me
if i love the job i'm doing i love the
things i'm doing
10 hours a day 15 hours a day it's
nothing
i think it's also important to reason
from first principles
rather than by analogy so the normal way
that we conduct our lives is we we
we reason by analogy it's we're doing
this because
it's like something else that was done
or it's like what
um other people are doing me too type
ideas
yeah it's like yeah slide iterations
yeah on on a theme
um and and uh
and it's it because it's it's kind of
mentally easier to reason
by analogy rather than from first
principles but my first principles is
kind of a physics way of
looking at the world and what that
really means is
you kind of boil things down to the most
fundamental truths
and and say okay what do we sure is true
or
sure as possible is true and then reason
up from there that takes a lot more
mental energy um
give me an example of that like what's
one thing that you've you've done that
on that you feels worked for you
sure so um somebody could say um
in fact people do uh that battery packs
are really
expensive and that's just the way
they'll always be because that's the way
they've been in the past
um you're like well no that's that's
pretty dumb
you know because if if if you apply that
reasoning to
anything new that then
you wouldn't be able to ever get to that
new thing how do you take a 12 million
revenue company to roughly 120 billion
revenue company without going public
what is the key
secret to doing that well the secret was
that
that i was as i said i didn't feel
i was fully using my capabilities so i
read everything i could
from all different all relevant
disciplines all different perspectives
to find principles that i could use
and apply in the business in my life to
enable me to believe in myself and i
started applying them in business
and they worked they worked beyond my
belief
and beyond anything i hoped for and that
absolutely transformed my life and so my
whole life has been
looking for principles that enable me to
contribute
uh or improve if the the principles
we're implying
and better apply them and
and so every day is like i'm reborn the
most important thing
uh aside from the things i've talked
about already
is it's really who you associate with
you want to associate with people that
are better than you are
i mean basically you'll go in the
direction of the people that you
associate with and
and you want to have the right heroes uh
you want people
if you want to emulate somebody you
better pick very carefully who you want
to emulate and uh
and when obviously you can't pick your
parents
uh uh they're gonna have an enormous
influence on you but you don't get a
choice on that but you get choices as
you go down the line and you
who you uh who you admire who you who
who you want to copy and the most
important
for most people in terms of that
decision is their spouse it's also
important in terms of a partner in
business but the partner in life is
is the most important one you want to
pick a spouse that's a little
that's better than you are and then he
or she
and hopefully you hope they don't figure
it out too fast
when i worked for other companies some
of them not to mention any names
were so bad they would treat people the
old way
i'm the boss here's what you're gonna do
because i'm the boss right
or there were times for example where
maybe had a dollar for lunch you can't
get a lot for a dollar
so i just knew that that's how i was and
if i had a company
that i had control of my gosh everyone's
going to be treated the way i wanted to
be treated
so the minute we could afford it
everyone had free lunch whether you had
money or not you have free lunch we pay
for it for you
carpool will pay for that so we started
doing things for people
that i wish happened to me maybe that's
part of fate
maybe because a lot of things along the
way weren't so good that as things
started getting good it was so
easy for me to share with our people so
easy to do that
people sometimes don't save money as
soon as we possibly could afford it we
started profit sharing we're at the end
of every year
and we'll take that profit sharing and
put in a retirement fund for you it's
yours
it's yours if you're so many years it
goes with you no matter where you go
but it's yours that's your money that's
really incredible and
how much do you think that that sort of
golden rule approach has fed into
your ridiculously low turnover rate
which is literally
almost unprecedented i mean that's crazy
i try and treat people
exactly the way they'd want to be
treated exactly the way i would have
wanted to be treated
i'm happy with my people i realized my
people are the company
if my people go my god the company goes
people are your company and they take
care of the customer the
customer is always right no matter what
so what do we do so the customers
happier
if somebody's unhappy would try and
discover why
and because you treat people this way
and we love them you walk in our company
it's love
if you go to the front desk here in
century city this girl just has the
biggest smile saying hi welcome to john
paul mitchell system she loves
what she does our big problem is we
don't have turnover we have so many
people out of work for us and the thing
is
you got to wait for somebody to die now
as we grow we'll add one or two on
obviously
at a time sure and we're pretty big now
because we're in 96 countries
it's how you take care of people
anywhere in the world you don't blossom
around
you including what you're doing there's
nothing that ai
won't impact as big as the um so bit
having been around a while i saw the
impact of pcs then i saw the impact of
local area networks
then i saw the impact of wide area
networks then i saw the impact of the
internet
then i saw the impact of mobile then i
saw the impact of wireless
you know now i'm seeing the impact of of
artificial intelligence
and it dwarfs any of those things and if
i don't understand how to apply it to my
businesses
i mean i remember selling pcs and
software and walking in saying
you don't need to use that pen and paper
on on a you know on a notepad
or a ledger pad now we're going to give
you a spreadsheet and by the way
here's a here's a spreadsheet that costs
495 dollars and i had to pay to go get
trained on how to sell it
which is crazy now when you think about
it but then we said okay now you can
play what if
then we said you can connect these pcs
unless i understood the technology how
was i going to explain it
how was i going to understand it unless
i understand it now how am i going to
invest in it
you know then i got to go trust somebody
who says oh yeah i know ai and
maybe they do maybe they don't and it's
really easy
just to have just to okay so you figure
it out that's just not my style
so you're building a base of knowledge
and then you think that at some point
it's going to pay dividends in terms of
already has
right i mean if you truly believe ai is
going to change
everything how are you going to
understand what people are doing to
change everything
unless you at least have a foundational
understanding of it
now i'm not going to build a million
layer neural network and try to change
the world and i'm not going to
show you i'm not going to write a
research paper and saying here's how why
the lottery ticket approach works and
you can build smaller neural networks
with less data and be more you know
resource efficient but i can read that
stuff and understand that when somebody
says okay we're building this project
and we need this size data set or this
size data set we need this amount of
resources
i can ask questions and understand the
answers everything that is happening to
us
is preparing us for whatever is to come
and literally we can see
that this moment has been a moment to
send us all to our rooms
literally for a time out and
whether we wanted to or not it's an
opportunity to reset
to re-organize to rethink where we are
and where we want to be and where we
choose to go
when this pandemic is over and we are
released
back into a new normal everybody keeps
saying we want things to go back to
normal
forget that folks forget that
let go of we want things the way they
used to be we cannot have had this
experience
without being forever changed and those
of us who
are carriers of the light seekers of the
light as you all
are seeking wellness know that you have
to move into wherever this moment is
carrying us so ask yourself what could
you
reset to help yourself be healthier
and well in this moment
in these moments that we're experiencing
no question about it
the pandemic the lockdown the separation
the social distancing
has caused us all to feel some sense of
disorder
i feel it too even though i i
literally am leaning into every
spiritual practice
i ever thought i believed in but it
still has caused
disorder and i'm asking myself the same
questions that i'm asking you to ask
yourself
what can the disorder reorder
for you we cannot let this moment
this extraordinary time that no one
in our lifetime has experienced pass
us by and us not get all that it's here
to teach impact show
and evolve us to so to me the
cornerstone
of any wellness is in vision
is focus so i found myself
at the beginning of this pandemic
feeling several things first
uh when lockdown came i was excited
because whoa
i thought it was only going to be like
two weeks and i was treating it like
vacation and i didn't have to fit into
any pants
so i was eating everything i was like
counting the points in my head but not
really tracking them and then when i
realized we're going to be longer i
thought
after i put on the first seven pounds i
said whoa
let's get ourselves refocused and back
on track i was feeling overwhelmed
well but i will tell you that for me
being the practice of of
being fully present has saved me and one
of the reasons i was feeling overwhelmed
and eating my way through the first two
weeks is because
i had just come off of that tour and i
saw many of you i see some faces that i
saw
on the tour hey lisa i see you there um
i um and i realized
you know as more and more information
was coming forward that
wow i after every show y'all
shook had 400 500 people
waiting in line to take pictures and
shaking hands so i shook hands i hugged
people
people kissed me i kissed them we cried
we danced we did
everything and then i thought
14 for the first 14 days
after the tour finish every day i was
waiting to
like know whether or not i was going to
be
a victim of covet 19. i
am in the at risk risk category i am 66
never before have i been reminded of
that number because at first when
the news started coming out about uh it
affecting elderly people i was like oh
so sad the elderly people then i
realized they were talking about people
over 60 oh they're talking about me
oh i didn't realize i was elderly
okay thank you so much and as i've
shared with so many of you i had
pneumonia last year so
i'm really in that category of ad risk
um so i was worried
and if you're watching the news every
day as i know we all have been
needed it for information i have now
stopped and limited that for myself
if you're watching the news every day
you can get overwhelmed with the stories
and i was reading every terrible
horrible story
of what it does to your body and how it
shuts down your lungs and then it makes
your heart race and then your kidneys
fail and
all of that okay do i have a witness
over there i see you linda
and so i had to stop i had to stop doing
that i had to stop doing that
and every time i would i would get
overwhelmed i would do this i would just
literally go to my breath and remind
myself that
breath is the presence of life it
reminds you that the breath is literally
the source
of life for you come back to focus and i
would say
in this moment i am well in this moment
i'm okay i am not in the hospital i am
not
on a respirator i am not that story in
this moment
i am breathing i am well i'm okay coming
back to the moment coming back to the
moment
reminding myself in this moment i am
well
so i believe that the first step toward
focus is to start
exactly where you are do you think you
do so well in business because you're
dedicated
to looking after your body and leading
an active lifestyle 100
i think if you can find an hour or two a
day for yourself
for your body then you're going to be
able to do
you know five or six more hours of
creativity throughout the day
and and we all know you know when we let
ourselves go
you know we're just not going to perform
as well so
you know one of the reasons we set up
health clubs
in pretty well every you know all the
major cities around the world is
um you know is it is a passion of mine i
think
it's so important that people you know
keep healthy
i think we are we as human beings are
endlessly curious about ourselves
and we're cute and we love to test
ourselves constantly we
and we and we find all sorts of arenas
to test ourselves in
and you can tell you know uh right now i
have a racing sale i had the fastest
racing sailboat in the world maybe the
the fastest racing sailboat in history
uh
sayonara has raced 26 times we have 24
firsts and two seconds
and i'm discovering all sorts of things
about
me as i race that boat uh i discover all
sorts about
all sorts of things about me every day
as oracle competes with microsoft for
supremacy in the software world
so there's a wonderful there's a
wonderful
saying that that's dead wrong uh that
says you know why did you climb the
mountain i climbed the mountain because
it was there that is
utter nonsense ludicrous and absurd
you climbed the mountain because you
were there and you were curious if you
could do it you wondered what it would
be like
uh you wonder what the view was from the
top
and that's how we explore
the thing that we're most interested in
interested in
is exploring our own limits and exp
and exploring our relationship with
others we're much more interested in
each other
and ourselves than we are everything
else showing up means
showing up it don't mean you got to the
office
you understand doesn't mean you came to
work
for me showing up means i show up i've
been showing up since i was
25 years old man before that i wasn't
showing up
i was showing off i was acting a fool
being a fool high school i didn't show
up i went to class i never showed up my
body went in the room
see showing up doesn't mean you got
there showing up means you got there
and then you showed up again and then
you showed up again and you showed up
again
means you show up for the class you show
up for the homework you show up for the
class you show up for the homework you
show up for the test
you freaking get a perfect grade means
you keep showing up to the next level
and i hear a lot of people talking about
showing up you know showing up's not
everything let me tell you something
showing up when you show up the right
way
johnny you got to put your seatbelt on
when you show up the right way when you
show up the right way
showing up is 100 of success
that means you show up and then you show
up again you show up again you keep
getting better at your game
you can't keep showing up as the old you
you got to show up as the new you you
know mercedes-benz
if they just kept building this vehicle
the way they used to build it
and didn't keep showing up with new
technology
new suspension new seats
new choices new colors
you know the matte black the red guts
new navigation system see if i can i
don't even know how to operate this
thing i can go to dynamic right now
heavy suspension
i can go to dynamic thrust here boom i
can go to super exhaust right here
cameras all over the place look at this
look at this board change like
like man i can just do all kind of trick
stuff with this thing i don't even know
how to do all this stuff
i wish the guy would have sold me the
car your your door's open by the
by the way johnny um the guy that sold
me the car i wish he'd show me how to
operate the car because i don't know how
i got cameras on the front of the thing
behind the thing
under the thing in the ass of the thing
on top of the thing i got
it's crazy now that what what is the
point of all that
you got you got you got to get your game
on folks
you want to be married happily married
you got to keep showing up
you can't have sex with your wife
tonight like you had with her last month
you got to have it a new way
you got to keep bringing gain new
strategies new moves on your game on
your marriage game kids
okay you got a kid that's three years
old trust me when that kid is
nine years old you will need a new game
with that kid
otherwise they're not going to listen to
you
in sales you got to have a new game
every day baby
you got to have a new game every day and
the follow follow-up you gotta have
you gotta have new follow-up you can't
have a new i can't can't do the same
thing you did that didn't work yesterday
we're doing a 10x growth conference i'm
doing a 10x this year
i'm not doing the same 10x i did last
year it's a new year new time new
audience
new speakers now that being said when i
show up in the 10x growth conference in
las vegas on 2
20 20 20 i just spent
six hours this morning working out what
we're doing
okay i'm not gonna show up the way i did
last year jumping out of a damn plane
i'm gonna show up in a different way
okay in a different way in a unique way
but i am not going to abandon the things
that work for the audience and for
myself
so you got to find this really really
cool mixture between
repeating what works and showing up as a
new person all the time
if you're reading a book okay you're
listening to music
going to an event uh
speaking at an event let's say you're
speaking in an event it's
it's the 700th time you did that
presentation you got to show up
new again johnny comes to work with his
camera
we're doing a show today johnny needs to
show up new looking for new angles new
colors new
you got to show up every day new folks
you're new man you're new
ladies and gentlemen you're new every
day you're new
or guess what you're old
[Music]
nobody wants old i don't want to get old
i don't want stale i don't want
yesterdays
i don't want leftovers i don't i don't i
know i know when somebody's repeating
something rote
they're just giving me the same i don't
mind some [ __ ]
but it's got to be fresh i need some
fresh bullsh
so i don't i don't mind a little bit of
[ __ ] i just don't want the same
thing
okay that guy's told that story a
thousand times and it looks like the
thousand
thousand times not in a good way either
so you gotta keep showing up showing up
means you're looking for deeper levels
to show up to pay attention
that's what i do every day every day i
come to work i'm like show up man show
up for every little problem
show up for every little opportunity
show up for every little
little nuance little angle
little particle little movement that's
why i see all this stuff
why is that not cleaned up why is this
not cleaned up what's it why don't
somebody pick that up
who's that new person here hey you
feeling all right today how many times
have i asked you that before you all
right today
i know it's little things it's simple it
costs nothing to do this show up
it costs you nothing and it makes all
the difference man showing up
you'll see things that no one else sees
and and you know the good news is
anybody can do this you just got to make
a commitment to show up
i grew up in lake charles louisiana for
those of you don't know my story and my
dad
uh my dad was
he had five kids wife he was dedicated
and committed to being the provider for
his family
like many of you are how many of you
provide for your family
probably want to do a good job at it my
dad wanted to do a good job at it so my
dad died when i was 10 years old he had
he had owned a
life insurance company he actually
started a life insurance company
it was taken from his him and a partner
it was taken from him
at the age of uh i guess he was 42 years
old
42 years old he's got five kids he's got
a wife to take care of and no job how
many have been in transition before
yeah so 42 a lot of obligation now
starting to move into the middle class
42 years old he's got
he's got twin boys coming they didn't
plan us
you know good catholic family doing the
planning every five years we'd
they'd have a baby so he was planning
you could tell like when i look back in
my in his life today there's a long
answer to a short question but
like like you guys you guys need to
figure out your your
why you're going to do whatever you're
going to do my dad knew why he was going
to do what he was going to do but my dad
didn't think big enough
it's it's it's it's a it's a i i got two
things for my dad one
every day he worked he was up early he
stayed late he's in transition
between 42 and 52 he's in transition in
his life
right he's having to go from life
insurance company big dream
company gets stolen away from him he's
like what am i doing
right this is the story of the middle
class right here this is called gravity
this is uh yesterday's miami bridge
falling
and everybody's like i can't believe
that happened
structures fall folks so this is what i
learned from my dad my mom had to sell a
dream house that was
paid for in cash my dad bought a dream
house a year and a half before he bought
before he died we all went in celebrated
oh my god this is unbelievable this
is crazy this is great we made it to the
middle class my dad dies
my mom has to sell the house a week
literally a week after my dad dies
when she should have been grieving she
was having to sell this dream house
you understand what i'm saying this is
what i learned when i was 10 years old
man life is short
okay my dad didn't provide he did he
worked hard but he didn't have enough
because if he had enough my mom would
not have had to sell the dream house
anybody agree with that
okay my mom did not know how to produce
new income
so my mom had to go into conservation so
when you asked me the question how did
you start
i started with the wrong data okay i
started with the wrong data
and the data was hey life is short
something bad is going to happen all
that's true
but if you could out produce if you
could produce enough income
you could start solving some of these
problems like indestructible income
it's saying hey man if you've got a
million dollars you're basically just a
freaking deadbeat
and that your daddy didn't tell you that
if you didn't have any more income
and you were how old are you
you're 27 years old i'm gonna do this at
47 i'm going to do it at uh
at at 65. 27
you don't have any more income how long
would that money last
at 4 000 a month you got 25 years
where can you live on four thousand
dollars a month you'd have to live on
four thousand dollars a month
for 25 years you will be 52 years old my
friend
and dead broke number one thing you got
to do is this
you got to change the target and you
need to look at the target daily
the target you have the wrong target
right now if you're struggling you have
the wrong target
when you change the target everything
changes
now and and i started with zero just so
you guys know i didn't have anything
okay so look it's simple target what's
your new target freedom
yeah freedom but but but let's put my a
number on it
your first target should be ten million
dollars and nothing short of that number
one the target number two
you need to get your income to a place
this is a fascinating concept right here
okay if you can do this i guarantee
you'll be rich you need to get your
income
not to what pays your bills but to where
you can save
40 percent of your gross income
is saved all right so now now when you
do this math you're like dude how much
money do i actually need let's kick this
up to 20 grand
at 20 grand what happens you're saving
eight
storage you're paying eight
and now you can live on four see now
this is the right way to do a budget
you make thirty thousand twelve is going
to storage
12 is going to the ir and the s
and that leaves you with six so now you
can start seeing
do you got to be somewhere north of 300
grand a year this is what they don't
teach you at harvard
you got to be somewhere north of 360 a
year before
you even have money to live on unless
you're just
you know you're direct you're just an
irresponsible human being
that that's you know not putting storing
money away for the future
okay now you're saving 12 grand a month
that's 144 000
in one year in 10 years that's 1.4
million dollars in 10 years you're a
millionaire
stored you guys need to be heavily money
motivated from a survival standpoint
okay number three thing you're gonna do
you're gonna go broke right here
and invest
the storage storage has to get invested
the golden goose is only good if she
lays eggs otherwise you can kill her eat
her for a chicken
need eggs bait money needs to make
babies
right so your goal right here is to
invest
to invest the storage money and continue
to do that
until this money over here the passive
money
is equal to
your income
[Music]
right so what would i do i'd go out i'm
gonna make 30 grand
i'm going to store 12 i'm going to pay
the irs i'm going to live on 6.
warren buffett says don't lose money
number one number two don't lose money
i would tell you number three don't lose
money and that's the reality of the
situation that's what peter
field was saying a single digit
millionaire
cannot even provide themselves with
their own
personal defense in america
okay hulk hogan all that money hulk
hogan made he blew it all
he blew it all probably buying hair
pieces
okay he blew it all he blew it all ended
up with a little money thought he was
the [ __ ] oh man i got a little money
until he had that freaking lawsuit
and then he can't even defend himself so
it happens to a lot of people
how many how many of you know a family
member lost their job
okay how many of you have a family
member where the kid got a drug
addiction he had to go to
a rehab for 30 days and it cost 40 grand
that happens how many of you know
somebody got cancer okay how many know
somebody in a car accident cost three or
four hundred grand
what happens okay the problem is not
that [ __ ] happens
it happens and people aren't ready for
it oh god i can't believe this happened
to me
oh [ __ ] really goddamn you've been
around long enough
right how many of you can't swim
you live on a planet with water i'm just
saying you might want to get a swimming
lesson
it's a wet planet i don't care who you
are
when people you've worked with supported
helped
uh done stuff with
when you hit a when you hit a band of
success
don't be shocked they gonna turn on you
too
oh yeah i'm serious your success feels
like a threat to them
it's freaking amazing
i'm sure they'll see this let's see
you'll see
you know they won't comment they won't
post
they just check out on you dude until
you got something to offer them
and then they like yeah man let's do
something together
so look i'm just prepping you if you're
one of those people out there like i was
when i was 25
30 35 40 45
waiting for my break man i'm busting my
ass every day
every day 250 days a year i'm banging
out weekends i'm getting ready to fly
out again
like i'm not complaining i'm not
bragging either
i'm just telling you if you're gonna
make it if you're one of those people
out there that like like this message
resonates with you
i never thought about spending two weeks
up in utah somebody's house look at this
place this freaking place is stupid
look at this skiing ski out it's one of
the only places in deer valley it's got
a swimming pool
a little cave back here i don't know
what people do in the cave
so yeah so look look uh here's the deal
nobody there's no course on this
nobody's going to teach you how to
handle it
but if you're going to hit it big and i
expect you're watching this
you're one of those people that want to
hit it big
man up number one don't hate up why you
while you're working your way up the
food chain don't hate up
okay it always falls back in your face
doesn't make you look good
anybody that is anybody knows what
you're doing and you see a lot of
guys out there playing games running
stories you know you see the 50 cent
uh mayweather those guys hating on each
other all the time you see some of the
rappers doing this
look this can't be your game okay
you're thinking about success people are
out creating producing
coming up with new material new ideas
new games
you don't have time to stop and hate or
even criticize other people
you could observe oh wow that was cool
oh i wouldn't do that
no reason to comment about it use the
data use the data
build your freaking empire create
success after success after success
stay focused don't be one of those
people right don't even check out on
those guys
like if you got somebody in your space
you're competing with they're taking
some of your market or you feel a little
bit of threat
threat by them try to collaborate with
them do stuff with them don't try to
like oh
i'm not you know i'm not going to
support him like when you support
somebody else's success
those people that make it they remember
it they remember it man they see it
i'm telling you you're not going to know
this you're going to think oh no dude
i'm going to get this
you're going to go from doing whatever
you're doing right now you got to
you got a one comma business you got a
hundred thousand dollar a year
business and then you go to a million
you got a couple commas in there now you
got six zeros you got this
you got a one make it a million you're
gonna feel it man watch you're gonna
have family and friends
family and friends start freaking huh
you work so hard
why are you working so hard money's not
everything and then for you to go from 1
million to 10 million
oh you become a threat to other people
man
people say oh that guy's on a move he's
on the move she's on the move
he's on the move she's on the move
you're going to try to do something with
them they're going to do something with
you once
don't be surprised when they stop
following you when they stop
supporting you when they stop liking
commenting working with
flowing your energy and power but look
when they stop don't you stop
be the bigger person be the bigger being
here
okay somebody's not gonna like it
because i i got a i don't have a shirt
on in the pool
i'm sure somebody's gonna say oh
cardone's at it again
all right
and when i'm down in miami and the sun's
shining down on me and that radiation's
hitting me i wear a shirt and you guys
like oh
why is he wearing a shirt you see it
doesn't matter you can't win man
you just can't win but you can win
look don't try to win the little games
with people
high school's over it's not a popularity
contest
okay you guys out there right now if
you're seeing this
you know who you are you did stuff you
talked about doing stuff
now you all you all you're acting like a
little baby like a little boy like a
little punk
like a punk you're acting like a punk
dude don't
don't do it don't do it what are you
doing man you're wasting energy
it's a long play baby there's only seven
billion people on this planet
the end of the you get at the end of the
day if you're going to get super
successful you're going to know them all
and the super successful end up knowing
the super successful because check it
out
if the super successful don't know who
you are yet that's cause you're not
super successful yet
so when you're hating on somebody in
your same space right or they're hating
on you remember this
you keep focused on creating massive
massive success
okay because when you get up to the top
of the food chain whatever the food
chain is in your space whether it's
financial or
insurance or real estate or influencers
or podcasters
or or maybe you're doing a real business
you're not doing it you're not an
influencer and you're not a podcaster
you're like
why all these guys spending all this
time doing podcasts i got a business to
grow i got employees
maybe you're doing that
so what's my point
anytime you watch any of my videos you
say dude what's the guy really talking
about
i'm doing this for you i don't get paid
to do it so if you're getting any value
out of this i'm telling you when you get
up the food chain and you will because
you're watching it you will get up the
food chain you will become a super
successful person
but you won't if you hate
you will not become super successful
if you take the time to worry about
these other people in your space
flowing power man love on them
send them love send them customers send
them deals but don't be surprised
when they don't send it back because
they're not
no book tells you this
all these guys doing their little quotes
talking about abundancy
scarcity but watch how they act when you
get up there man watch it man it's gonna
be crazy you're gonna be like cardone
told me
while i was eating snow the dude told me
that they were going to hate on me i had
i had somebody call me the other day and
said hey dude i want to give you some
you need you need to know how to handle
some of these situations you're running
up against
okay because there's a way for you to
prevent some of this
some of these people hating on you i
said dude i don't i'm not gonna try to
prevent somebody from being stupid
that's just dumb i got enough insurance
in my life already
most of the time the accident never
happens the way to ensure
that these haters and criticizers and
little thinkers don't bother you is
don't be them
number one number two keep following
them love and power baby number three
number three number three get to the top
get to the top of the food chain
where everybody at the top knows you
and the people that wouldn't flow you on
the way up
or wish they didn't do what they did
okay
[Music]
it better be big because it's gonna be
hard either way it's gonna be hard so it
better be big
because if it's not big it won't be
worth it
[Music]
it's like spinning spinning spinning
it's like
juggling it's like you know
anybody else can buy this place to do
this
if you had all the money like unlimited
budget
what would you spend money on
we're doing the due diligence on a
property in houston texas actually
pasadena let's go see what we find out
huh what most people don't understand
about the real estate game i don't need
35 million to become 70 million to make
money
i need the 10 million i put down i need
to be worth 45 when i exit for my 10
million to double
and i got paid while i sat and wait
money money
this is my guy right here man god bless
you bro mr lander god bless you
you phenomenal hey man
how are you doing man i watched your
videos all the time that's awesome man
it's hard you just gotta hang in there
buddy you gotta hang in there you gotta
you gotta figure out like like maybe a
little left or a little right you got to
just
keep working it out and you figure it
out don't give up man
[Music]
[Music]
little short arm swinging lego up
spinning up you want to sell something
for 35 million dollars you better
put the spit shine on it
[Music]
you guys that are going to play with me
at cardone capital
get your money right get your money in
because we're gonna make some money
again and again
stay in tune stay in touch we're gonna
let you what work what we're gonna let
you know what works
when it doesn't work when it's trouble
and when we score
i don't know about these puppies they
never work for me but this one's got
octopuses on it which is my favorite
animal
why eight arms tentacles that suck and
never let go
800 keep coming keep coming the rest of
it
the yellow one
[Music]
we're on our way to to do some business
some work
with 40 000 entrepreneurs business
people
from all over the world
i'ma bless this place with more
greatness you see you need to find
places that have greatness in a man and
drop more greatness in
i'm going to go for my bio screen to
that i'm going to get everybody to do it
at the same time and just show
what what an alliance of action looks
like
really really appreciate i love you guys
i love you guys
this has been a lifelong dream of mine
to one be with you and to be with wfg
never never take advice from your
twitter if they quit
you do not get advice from them my goals
have always been based on the people
around me
i'm gonna make 50 grand why because my
daddy made 50 grand
[Applause]
i just got done doing a gig for this guy
right here super
unbelievable audience inspirational
speeches i've ever had
and i am so grateful and thankful that
you are part of our company now
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
we want you coming exciting we want you
coming with us i'm talking about
everyday people
ordinary people people that don't like
us you feel like you don't have a shot
right now
things are tough we've been there okay
we know what you're going through go all
the way to the top
[Music]
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
most people are crazy busy but don't get
anything
done if you feel like you're crazy busy
like you barely have any enough time for
yourself that you get to the end of the
week
and you know you've been you've been
hauling ass all week long you've been
you've been busting your face in you've
been working and working and working
super busy but then you look back and
you say what did i actually do this week
if that's you then this message is for
you you're busy
but you're not focused and shifting your
life begins with shifting your
priorities
so i used to pride myself on responding
to email
asap quickly like you send me an email
30 seconds to 60 seconds later you would
get my response
i prided myself on like that's good
service that's what you should do
as an entrepreneur right like people
communicating with you you want to send
it back to them quickly i hated
having to wait and wait and wait on
people so i didn't want to be that for
others so i had all my notifications
turned on and as soon as an email came
in
ding came in boom response go what made
it worse was people would then get my
response they
tended to be on the computer at the same
time and then they write back right away
and say
wow you're really quick like thank you
so much
and that fed that fed the identity that
fed the ego and
i am very fast exactly right there's
proof that this thing works
the problem was i wasn't getting
anything important done
i was working on something and then the
notification came in and i stopped what
i was working on to go answer this email
feel great about myself that little hit
and then come back to my project like
what was i working on
and it it takes time to start getting
back into the flow of work in that thing
and then another email comes in
and so i ended up being busy i was
working all day long
all day long right like lunch at the
desk breakfast at the desk dinner at the
desk all day long
right washroom back to the desk there
was no breaks
all day long straight through when i get
to the end of the day
out of the week like what did i do this
week
i don't know but i answered a lot of
emails
because i didn't have focus i didn't
have priorities and when i realized that
after that happened enough times i
realized wow
this is i'm never getting close to my
goals like just doing this all i'm doing
is reacting to other people's goals
when somebody shoots me an email that's
what they want they're demanding my time
and i'm giving it to them freely because
i have no defense around my time because
i i have no respect for my time i'm just
letting it bleed out
there's no time for me to work on what i
want and so i'm not going to make any
progress on the things that i want
if you want to make progress on the
things that you want you have to carve
out time for the things that you want
that's how it works and you got to put
gates and blockades and barriers around
and say this is my focused time
and nobody's allowed in now worst case
emergencies
family awesome but there aren't that
many actual emergencies
you have to be willing to let the small
balls drop
to go for the big goals in your life you
have to pick you can't do both
really well you have to pick what do you
want to be great at do you want to be
great at getting every little small
thing done
and then never do the big thing or do
you want to be great at getting the big
things done
and risk losing some of the small things
because by chasing down the big things
you're going to lose some small things
i'm going to give a three-step process
follow along and let's change your life
step number one deciding your top three
goals right now what are your top three
goals most important things to you right
now what are your priorities
the three big things that have to happen
for you what are they get clear
get specific if you don't know what they
are that's why you're not chasing
anything big down
if you even thought about it then then
that's the problem you're stuck in these
small projects for life
what are your three big goals for your
business and your life right now
step two was map your actions to your
ambitions whatever you say you want to
do will not happen unless it's in your
calendar you need to
map your actions what you're doing to
your ambitions what you say you want
what you're doing has to lead to what
you say you want out of life
you can say you want all this stuff but
if you're not doing the work you're
never going to get there
and most people live there you say you
want this but you're doing something
totally different over here
because it's on your calendar you
haven't prioritized it so now it's time
to pull up your calendar
and map your actions to your ambitions
for those three goals you need to put
time
in your calendar every week to make
progress on them you have to
your calendar is never going to
miraculously open up there's only going
to be more people who have demands to
your time and want you to react to their
life
to their emergencies to their goals
instead of you fulfilling your own
so pull out your calendar and show
yourself where
in the week you're gonna block off the
time to map your actions to your
ambitions
and make time to make those three goals
of yours happen
so step three is block the time and take
small losses for big wins
physically put into your calendar this
block of time on monday afternoon i'm
spending on xyz
and i am okay with losing some small
losses
i will not be reachable i might lose a
deal there might be some
burn down happening that i can't take
charge of i'm going to disappoint
somebody i'm going to let somebody down
not with not with intentionally not on
purpose
but it's going to happen and you're not
going to kick yourself for doing it
because what you're going to make you're
going to make that time count
those two hours four hours six hours
eight hours however long you're spending
working on your goals
you're gonna make that time count you're
sacrificing all these small wins that
you love going after
to make this time count so use that as
pressure
not to feel guilty about yourself for
not doing those little small wins
and being linked and getting back to
people but in saying i am working on
something that's going to change my
life and because of these people who are
dependent on me for everything else and
i'm pushing that off i better make this
time count
use that pressure to drive you forwards
instead of backwards you have the power
to control your world how you
think how you act your mindset with the
words that you speak
when you use weak language you signal to
yourself that you are weak
you signal to yourself that your goals
aren't important you signal to yourself
that you are not worth it
you lose respect for yourself and the
people around you don't respect you
either
we need to stop using weak language and
pay attention to the words that you're
speaking to others
and to yourself now this is not an easy
task
because most of the words that you're
using the way that you talk to others
into yourself you're on autopilot you're
on cruise control it just happens you've
been doing this for years or decades
and so switching it is not going to
happen overnight but if you pay
attention to the next three things that
i'm going to share with you
it can have a dramatic impact on your
self-confidence and the goals that you
have for yourself and on the outcomes
you create for yourself and the world
let's do it number one i can't i'm not
i don't what you say after those three
things shapes your identity
it speaks to how you think and speak
about yourself
so i can't i can't be an entrepreneur i
can't be a leader i can't be a youtuber
i can't i can't i can't i can't i can't
especially this one when you say i can't
pay very very very very very very close
attention
to what follows and try and try
and try to shift it from i can't
to either i choose not to or i can't
yet i'm not i'm not a good salesperson
i'm not funny i'm not the kind of person
who follows through
again pay close attention and try to
shift it to not
yet i don't i don't program
i don't know how to make money i don't
think like that
switch i don't do i don't yet
i can't i'm not i don't those statements
are final
those statements don't allow for growth
those statements are how you feel about
yourself and don't allow for the stretch
they don't allow you to get better and
so either eliminate them from your
vocabulary
or change them to yet number two is
catch your cruise control
the way that you have been speaking
about yourself the way that you have
been talking to yourself
has been happening using the same words
for years
maybe even decades it's so automatic for
you
you are on cruise control you are on
autopilot you think small and talk
negatively about yourself without even
thinking about it you need to catch your
cruise control
and listen don't be too hard on yourself
this is so ingrained these patterns have
been around for so long you are just
auto defaulting to cruise control that
most of these times you will not even
catch it
you will not catch 99 of these moments
of these words of these languages that
you're using for yourself
but if you have the awareness if you
have the intention if you have the
desire
every now and then you will catch it
another quick hack is to enlist a friend
and list the people around you your wife
your husband your team your kids
kids especially my son hayden loves
calling me out on things
enlist their help tell them this is
where i want to play a bigger game
this is where i'm frustrated with myself
this is where i keep talking badly about
myself and putting myself down these are
the words the language that need to
change
and every time you hear me talking this
way i need you to bring it to my
awareness
and let me know because i want to catch
my cruise control
for me personally it's around
complaining anytime i complain i want my
wife i want my team i want my son i want
the people around me to say evan you are
complaining
right there that was a complaint eat it
right i'm happy for them to hug me with
it to yell at me with it i just want
them to let me know
now when i told everybody they said
listen you barely complain you're like
the least complaining person that we
know
awesome thank you i'm humbled but i
still complain
and i probably complain a lot and a lot
of the times i'm missing it and so
please please please please please
please please
even if you think i'm great at it if you
catch me complaining i want you to call
me out on it
so enlisting your friends can be really
helpful because you will likely not
catch most of them yourself but it's
imperative
that you start working on catching your
cruise control step number three is
manual
override you have caught your cruise
control you have found the autopilot
it's about to happen again this negative
talk that you're about to speak out into
the world about yourself or your ideas
you putting yourself down is about to
come out again or has just come out
what do you do about it because this is
really important
if you catch yourself playing small or
talking negatively about yourself if you
catch it
and you don't do anything it actually
makes it worse
it's better that you don't even catch it
at all if you catch it and you recognize
i am playing small right now and you
ignore
it and you don't change your behavior
you are building that identity for
yourself
that you are somebody who is playing
small
you are consciously building that
identity for yourself and you need to
stop it
it makes it worse where when you do
catch it
when you find yourself falling into
those patterns those behaviors that you
don't want anymore whether you find it
yourself or somebody's calling you out
on it
what do you do you need to kick your
manual override into action and take the
action that you want because that starts
building
the positive habit that starts building
the positive respect
this is how you build respect for
yourself this is how you start building
the muscle
this isn't just a zero-sum game this
isn't just we go back to
neutral when you catch it you either go
sliding down or you go propelling up
the choice is yours when you catch
yourself playing small when you catch
yourself coming off a cruise control
you have to do the thing that builds the
self-respect up
and speak positively about yourself and
do the thing that you are scared to do
you need to have a financial plan or
you're going to end up broke this
happens to so many entrepreneurs
you're putting everything you've got
back into your business which is
uh not that bad a strategy to be honest
because at least you're getting the
compounding on your business
but a lot of what happens is you end up
super cash poor
and if anything happens to your company
you're screwed
all of that work that you put in all the
money that you put in all the
investments you put in
you've got nothing you've got no backup
plan and
this flies in the face a little bit of
the go all in
have no plan b no backup plan don't give
yourself an option burn the boats
but having a financial plane
that allows you to
be safe be comfortable have that nest
egg in the future is really really
really important i can't tell you how
many entrepreneurs i've
met who are so focused on building their
business
and then when you ask them about their
own financial plans and their
investments and what they're doing it's
it's nothing they have no plan if their
business goes away they're completely
out of luck they're completely screwed
and so you need to start having that
financial plan so that you don't end up
with a major loss or being 60 and having
nothing to fall back on
i think it's important to get started
now so here's how i do it
when i'm looking at my projects i want
to spend 40
as a maximum on operations so everything
is based off of revenue
and this this video is going to get a
little more technical than i usually do
so let me know if you like it
uh in the comments below when i'm
looking at my budgeting
nina and i look at this every every
month so nina's in charge of my
operations
she's in charge of all the bank accounts
she's in charge of all the payments
she keeps a tight chip running when i
look at my
revenue numbers my operational budget
is 40 of revenue so to make this
video right to make my youtube channel
happen
uh for my editing team for my research
team for my thumbnail team
for my gear for you know my salary all
of that stuff
has to be 40 max of the revenue
and so at the beginning if it's just you
then
then don't start spending too far ahead
of the curve right i hate spending money
until i'm making money so these numbers
can still apply you can come up with
your own version of it
but the numbers still apply no matter
how much revenue you're making
you just stop spending more than you're
making that's like a that's a great
start at the beginning so many
entrepreneurs are looking for ways to
spend money
stop spending money until you're making
money that's that's the first great
bit of financial advice i would put in
and still do for a new project
i put in my time my energy my hustle my
heart but not my money
until i'm making money so once you're
making the money even a little bit of
money you're making 100 bucks
right 40 goes towards operations so you
got to buy
a camera and the camera cost you 100
bucks
that's a pretty cheap camera but still
whatever then you have to wait till you
have 400 bucks in revenue
right so you have your revenue and then
40 goes to operations at least for me
you can you can adjust these numbers for
your own business
25 for me goes to
advertising marketing uh any promotional
expenses
so that would also uh include travel in
the past
i'm not traveling right now because of
kovid but that would include my travel
that would include
any conferences that i was going to
where i wasn't getting paid to go and i
had to cover my own flight
and my own hotel so anything that's
related to advertising to marketing
that would be within 25 so i have a i
have an advertising budget
and this was actually hard for me to
start spending money
as my business group because i was so
i'm still in the mindset of i'm the
entrepreneur who
ate beans for lunch every day because i
was making 300 bucks a month
and so the idea of spending thousands
and thousands of dollars
on marketing uh
every day is it seems crazy
it seems crazy anyway i had to get over
it i still struggle with it but we're
getting there
so having the budget helps me right
having the budget
to spend money helps me so 40
is operations 25
is advertising marketing 10 is savings
so we take 10 of whatever whatever i
made whatever the cash flow was coming
in and we put that away and so that's
where then i'm investing that's the
tony robbins compounding strategy i
invest half of it into an index fund
that tracks the canadian stock market so
half of my money just basically tracks
the canadian stock market
the fees are super low on it and it's a
way better return than you'll get on a
mutual fund
and then the other half right now is
mixed between
facebook and amazon so i'll take
more of a flyer on half the money and
then the other half will be
much more safe just put into an index
fund so ten percent of whatever i make
in the business goes towards savings and
investments
five percent goes towards giving away
so my wife nina also loves to help and
loves to support other people
just just like i do and in my book built
to serve i talked about
one of the biggest things i missed when
i was looking through
what makes nina happy is being able to
to help other people
uh and and donate the causes so we
created a fund
where five percent of what we make goes
towards helping people
and she gets to pick that might be a
charity
that might be a dog rescue that might be
someone in her family
that might be you know supporting
somebody that she knows that might be
somebody's going through a hard time and
she's going to help them out that might
be
contributing to the education fund of
her nieces or nephews like
that changes every month so every month
we get a budget
five percent of whatever we make goes
towards supporting the people in our
lives and she gets uh
she gets to be in charge of that we just
make sure that it adds up to
a max of five percent and that's great
again we weren't doing enough of that in
the past
and five percent may not seem like a big
number but
even if you're making a thousand bucks
and you spend 50 bucks on somebody
by giving it makes you feel
more full it makes you feel more
energetic more optimistic more positive
more happy
and 50 bucks is enough you know 50 bucks
would make a big difference for somebody
if somebody helped you in your business
in your life
and you you get five people ten dollar
gift cards
with a with a handwritten note to say
thank you that can make a big difference
that'll make you feel really good
and that energy will translate into more
growth
in your life and in your business so
having that five percent especially for
nina i'm
i i give my time i give my time so i'll
speak at events for free i'll coach
people for free
i like to give my time that's my giving
nina is finding ways to give
our money and she gets to pick causes
that are important to her so it's very
rarely
kind of entrepreneurial causes it's more
charities that are close to her or
family or friends or people in our lives
that
that she just wants to help so
40 towards operations 25 towards
uh marketing advertising ten percent
toward savings
five percent towards helping other
people
and then the rest is towards new
projects so if i'm if i'm launching
something new
and i want to put some investment in
this is another one that's been
difficult for me to overcome because
again i hate spending money totally
making money
and so now we're at the point where my
time is more valuable than my money
at the beginning it was the flip at the
beginning i'm making 300 bucks a month i
have no money
uh it's just really hard and so i'm just
putting all of my time my time my time
my time my time in
now the time becomes a lot more valuable
and and so i'm
spending a little bit ahead of the curve
and again having that budget
helps me do it for me pulling 10 aside
to save was the easiest part
the spending on the sales and marketing
the spending on the operations the
spending on the new project suspending
on the giving away
was the thing i needed more help with
and as i do those things it allows me to
get more of the results that i want and
so
that's my financial plan as of right now
and we'll make some tweaks and some
changes and and
minor adjustments along the way but it's
super important that you have one
and even if you're again making 500
bucks a month
a thousand bucks a month 2 000 bucks a
month
that the percentages can still apply
because when you can say hey i'm only
going to spend
40 of my revenue on operations
it forces you to be more resourceful
people complain about
lack of resources i don't have enough
money to do what i want to do
i don't have enough team members to do
what i want to do and as long as you're
stuck in the complaining mode of not
having enough resources
you'll never win entrepreneurship is
always about resourcefulness
much more than resources what can you do
with what you do have
and when you have those strict rules to
say i'm only going to spend
40 percent on operations i am going to
save 10 of what i make
every month even though it may not seem
like big numbers yet
right now it can make a huge huge huge
difference for you to one start to build
the discipline
into it but then also allow for the
compounding impact
everywhere because if you're saving 10
every month that will compound itself up
but if you're
giving away five percent or whatever
number works for you
every month that has a compound impact
as well
for yourself for your momentum for the
people in your life if you're investing
into advertising for 25 that has a
compounding
impact as well because they may not
recognize you after the first thing that
they see
after the first marketing campaign but
if you stick around
right all of these things add up and
we're spending i think way too much time
one just buying stupid things that don't
matter but also
investing into the operations of our
business instead of being more
resourceful to find ways to make things
happen
so create that financial plan give
yourself the best shot at a happy life
at a successful business
in a financially free future with money
in your bank account
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there